[Musique]
depuis 1978 est une grande attraction
touristique
les gens y viennent photographier filmer
pique-niqué contempler une réalisation
prodigieuse de l'homme un des plus
grands trous de la planète
c'est la mine à ciel ouvert d'un bar
dans le nord ouest de l'allemagne près
de cinq kilomètres de long la plus
profonde de tout près de 300 mètres sous
le niveau de la mer
la mine est tellement gigantesques que
les plus grands d'excavatrices du monde
paraissent presque minuscule dans ce
paysage dantesques les immenses godet de
chaque machine gruchet 248 tonnes de
terre et de minerai par jour le minerai
c'est du lignite une roche sédimentaire
restes fossiles de plantes la mine de en
mars est la plus grande l'autre ses
gardes feiler pas beaucoup plus petit
[Musique]
ce charbon le lignite et le plus
pollueur de la planète
s ligne était mouillée et il n'est pas
efficace en termes de kilos joule quand
ils brûlent et il aimait beaucoup de co2
milgram par kilowattheure c'est la
manière la plus sale de produire de
l'électricité
et l'allemagne est la championne du
monde de l'extraction et de
l'utilisation de lignes et 17% du total
mondial devant la chine
paradoxes et contradictions
éoliennes et charbon sale d'allemagne
qui est en train de fermer toutes ses
centrales nucléaire depuis la
catastrophe de fukushima au japon
produit 50 % de son électricité avec des
énergies renouvelables le soleil mais
surtout le vent impressionnant
mais encore 24 % de son électricité est
fournie par le charbon
et l'allemagne se chauffent au gaz russe
qui n'est pas très écolo non plus les
mines de hambach et de gaz salaires sont
entourés de six centrales thermiques
dont une seulement est arrêté
greenpeace est en guerre contre les
producteurs de charbon qui veulent
encore s'étendre
garde feiler est une des plus grosses
mines d'allemagne ils veulent encore
l'étendre dans cette direction en
détruisant six villages là bas vous
voyez l'église de kaysersberg et lutz et
rate
kaysersberg a déjà perdu 60% de ses
habitants dont les maisons ont été
achetées par la mine mais les autres
résister en ont fait un bastion alex
france journaliste enquête les connais
tous las tous ont réussi à bloquer
l'expropriation depuis deux ans et ils
attendent un verdict des tribunaux
ce qu'ils veulent éviter c'est le sort
du village de mannheim aujourd'hui ville
fantôme
si l'église demeure ainsi que quelques
bâtisses c'est parce que l'expulsion des
habitants a été jugé illégal le reste a
été rasée il ne reste que quelques
habitants qui refusent de partir
l'autre village menacé ces luttes ceyrat
autrefois 250 habitants ce qui reste de
lutte ceyrat c'est une grosse ferme et
quelques bâtisses seul le fermier
résister attend aussi une décision de
tribunal la mine veut aussi agrandir son
trou car sous le village il y a de 6 à 9
millions de tonnes de lignite
alex france à documenter la destruction
en photo tout a été rasé en cinq jours
nout ceyrat se trouve tout au bord du
trou gardé par la police et la sécurité
de la mine
tous les dimanches des citoyens y
manifestent
la résistance s'organise
dans le bois qui jouxte la ferme des
groupes de jeunes construisent un
village de tentes ou de cabanes dans les
arbres il se prépare à y rester
longtemps la bataille pourrait être
longue
ces jeunes sont parfois membres de
groupes plus radicaux tout le monde a en
mémoire les expulsions de la forêt de
hama en 2018 les manifestants ont perdu
la bataille risque il reste de la forêt
moins de 10% de l'original est pour
l'instant préservé c'est elle qu'on voit
au bout de l'ancienne autoroute elle
aussi expropriés
entre l'allemagne et le charbon c'est
une longue histoire que les allemands
vont revivre dans le musée de la ruhr à
essen en visite guidée la machinerie des
mines de charbon fermé en 1986 et des
usines de coque a été soigneusement
préservé pour les nombreux visiteurs
dans ce qui a été le coeur de la
puissante économie allemand 200 ans de
fer et d'acier
fondée par les familles krupp et thyssen
entre autres est mise au service de l'
empire prussiens de la fin du 19e siècle
et des régimes allemands successifs pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
les allemands croit-il que leur pays
peut se passer du charbon maintenant ce
ne sera pas facile
on en a encore besoin dans l'industrie
de l'acier
il faudra s'en passer ce n'est pas
écologique
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on pourra s'en
passer je suis allé dans les mines de
charbon brens et dévastateur pour
l'environnement et le paysage je suis
tout à fait contre
la compagnie qui exploite les mines de
lignite c'est la r w11 conglomérat
multinational de l'énergie basé non loin
à essen c'est le deuxième producteur
d'électricité d'allemagne à 60% avec du
charbon ses émissions de co2 la place au
premier rang des pollueurs européens
r w o est en transition nous a répondu
son porte parole qui n'a pas accepté
d'entrevues dans un courriel luijten
affirme que 90 % des investissements de
r w eux vont dans des projets verts et
durable qu'elle possède un parc
d'éoliennes dans la région rhénane des
mines de lignite il écrit que les mines
seront fermés plus tôt que prévu fin
2029 sauf carte valère ce sera plus tard
on croit que ce sera de me 38 et enfin
que le charbon de lutte c'est raté
nécessaires immédiatement ainsi que
celui des cinq villages alentours
pour alimenter leurs centrales
thermiques
[Musique]
ce qui pourrait changer la donne c'est
un nouveau gouvernement les allemands
sortent dans la rue pour réclamer la fin
du charbon
angela merkel et son dauphin qui vient
justement de la région rhénane armin
laschet tu avais fixé la sortie du
charbon à 2038 si olaf scholz du spd
social démocrate allié au parti vert
parvient à former un gouvernement cette
sortie sera avancé à 2030
lutte c'est raté devenue le point
central de la lutte contre le charbon
bras greenpeace il ya une permanence
avec ces deux roulottes juste en face de
la ferme du dernier résistant du village
on lit sur la façade 1° cinq élus tirade
sur vie 1 degré 5 c'est la limite du
réchauffement climatique moyen fixé par
l'accord de paris pour éviter la
catastrophe écologique
c'est la frontière la ligne rouge et
elle passe par l'ugtt et rate
ce ne sera pas facile de la respecter ni
pour l'allemagne ni pour bien d'autres
pays